mais avant ces nouvelles les couleurs
d'automne grise comme la pluie les
terres du sud est sont toujours inondées
et les habitants sont parfois réticents
à quitter leurs maisons malgré les
conseils pressants des pompiers agnès
vahramian et jean françois georges et y
sont allés au nord d'avignon 200 fois
aujourd'hui
l'hélicoptère a survolé la plaine le
rhône est venu loin à 5,6 kilomètres de
son lit baigné les ferme isolée au
milieu des cultures des maisons encore
habité mission de reconnaissance cette
famille ne donnera aucun signe de
détresse mais les pompiers ne lui
laisseront pas le choix il faut partir
maintenant car le fleuve continue de
monter évacué pour ne pas compliquer
plus tard la tâche des secours
la crue a été très progressive
chacun a été prévenu mais s'est laissé
en fait surprendre
on savait que ça a débordé mais pas on
ne pensait pas devoir sortir ces gens là
sont restés ils n'avaient pas d'eau
quand on les a avisés bien entendu mais
après on a reçu des multitudes appel
nous signale à un mètre d'eau à
l'intérieur ils n'ont pas voulu nous
écouter une fois de plus sous ce cas
nous passent la départementale 994 au
bout un groupe de maisons cela revienne
après leur évacuation
l'appui d'un maître sega 1 mètre 50 mais
les voisins sont encore là et n'en
démordent pas navet la nourriture et de
quoi manger
d'abord quand même pas bien dans le
cadre ampleur ne venez pas fait ce sont
ses habitants qui donne du souci aux
pompiers combien sont-ils encore comment
vont-ils passer la nuit
déjà 450 évacués aujourd'hui et la
décrue qui n'est toujours pas annoncée
ce soir
finie la ronde des hélicoptères la
famille hélitreuillée tout à l'heure est
en sécurité
l'attak